in the public interest the Westinghouse
Broadcasting Company and the University
of Pittsburgh one of the nation's major
health centers in cooperation with the
American Medical Society and the United
States Public Health Service bring you
the silent Invader and up to the minute
report on Asian influenza
how do you do I'm Carl eins throughout
history mankind has been forced to wage
many battles in order to protect his
family or Nation against Misfortune
disaster or even possible Extinction
now sometimes these wars
have been well within catastrophic
there was the catastrophe of 1918 when
an influenza epidemic swept through our
own Nation as well as the entire world
unlike the battles of nation against
Nation or Humanity against the forces of
nature when man has often had an
opportunity to prepare himself the
battles against disease throughout the
centuries have often found man in the
unfortunate position of having to combat
this enemy only after it had infiltrated
his community and infected much of the
population
recently you've become aware of a
pandemic or a worldwide epidemic which
originated in the Far East and is now
known as Asian influenza
because of the alertness and efficiency
of the United States Public Health
Service and the World Health
Organization a detection system similar
to that of the aircraft spotting has
been established throughout the world
and has enabled us to recognize and
follow the progress of Asian influenza
as it circles the globe
Health authorities expect an outbreak
this fall and winter in the United
States but not in such portions as in
the 1918 epidemic
and all the man upon whose shoulders
rests the responsibility for preparing
the United States for the impending
battle with Asian influenza is Dr LeRoy
e Bernie Surgeon General of the United
States Public Health Service
Dr Barney I imagine you and your staff
have been Gathering quite a tremendous
amount of material on Asian flu
it seems to me that everybody I know has
had and has talked about influenza but I
don't think anyone really knows pointed
it hits
Carl it's a one of the upper respiratory
infections something like a cold only
it's caused by a flu virus and the
difference between the Asian influenza
and the influenza that we've been having
all of these past few years is that this
strain began in the strain of the virus
began in Hong Kong and spread from Hong
Kong to the rest of the world including
the United States
well every year influenza is a problem
in our communities I'm sure it is in
yours too uh why are we suddenly so
concerned about it now
well that's a very good question we are
concerned because in the other countries
in which it's appeared and even in the
outbreaks that we've had so far in this
country the attack rate has been 15 to
20 percent of the population
and this attack rate occurs in about
four to six weeks for example in
Metropolitan Pittsburgh with
approximately 1 million people
if we had this flu strike here you would
have approximately two hundred thousand
people who would become ill in a four to
six weeks period and this of course
would make a tremendous impact upon the
economy of this particular area
that's understandable well we've all
heard of outbreaks here in this country
Dr Bernie of exactly how far has it
spread
well it's spread all over the United
States the first cases occurred uh
surprisingly enough on the East Coast
rather than on the west coast among Navy
personnel at Newport Rhode Island
and then the second group occurred a few
days later in both Navy and civilian
Personnel in San Diego since that time
of course which was about the first of
June it has spread then localized
outbreaks through Grinnell Iowa to the
Boy Scout Jamboree in Pennsylvania to
Louisiana and to actually almost all of
the states in the United States I didn't
realize that actually that was the Asian
flu that hit that Jamboree in our own
state it was Asian food that's right
plus well from what I've been able to
learn Dr Bernie not many people have
died as a result of Asian influenza in
the rest of the world now do you think
the same will hold true here in the
United States
we have
the belief now based upon the experience
of Asian influenza in the other
countries in South America at the
present time where it is in epidemic
proportions and as a result of the
outbreaks in this country so far that it
is a mild infection and with a very low
mortality rate and we believe that it
will continue to be both a mild
infection and have a very low death rate
well is the possibility that Asian flu
might turn into if I may use the word a
killer
well that is the possibility of course
and that has happened in preceding years
when we have had epidemics back in 1888
when we had a large epidemic and then
many of us recall the 1918 9 19 epidemic
when we had a mild influenza epidemic in
the spring of 1918 and then in the fall
we had a large outbreak of very virulent
influenza followed by serious
complications and then another wave hit
us in the February or March of 1919 at
that time as you may recall in that
whole period we had about 20 million
cases in the United States and about 850
000 deaths
but I would like to add that conditions
are quite different now than they were
then in the first place we have a mild
strain of influenza not a virulent
strain the second place we have the
antibiotics to combat any complications
that might arise which we did not have
in 1918.
well doctor with the disease spreading
so rapidly what exactly now are we doing
to combat it
well actually Carl we are doing trying
to do three things one is to develop as
rapidly as possible the only preventive
agent that we have against influenza and
that is the vaccine against this
particular strain of the vaccine of the
virus
and that is being done in six of the
large pharmaceutical manufacturers of
this country The Strain was collected by
an alert U.S Army medical team in Tokyo
and sent back to this country and then
given to the U.S Public Health Service
we distributed to the manufacturers and
they in turn actually began to
manufacture the vaccine before we had
had the first case in this country
so now our job is to get more of that
vaccine available and to get the public
use it number two we have to be prepared
to take care of the individuals who
become ill and we have been working
since early June with the American
Medical Association the American
Hospital Association State and
territorial Health officers voluntary
groups and others to prepare for taking
care of those who become ill and finally
the matter of having an alert and an
informed public one who will be aware of
the facts without being unduly alarmed
and certainly this program of the
Westinghouse Broadcasting Company is a
good example of Public Service to have
an alert but not an alarm public
well Dr Bernie you and your Public
Health Service crew if I can use that
word crew have certainly seen to make
great strides in order to get us ready
for this possible epidemic in such a
very short time
but we've had a lot of help I can assure
you Carl in doing this it hasn't been a
one man or one organization uh Joel as I
said previously we have had the full
cooperation in support of the American
Medical Association in both the
educational as well as the medical care
part and then in working with the
manufacturers to get them to manufacture
the vaccine and to stop other activities
and to build up their staffs
I think we can all be proud of the
industry which we have in this country
it's another example of the know-how and
the expeditious way in which free
enterprise through our American industry
can do a good job the
vaccine or the virus was given to the
industries about the middle of May and
within three months vaccine was being
released through our National Institute
of Health as being both a safe and an
effective vaccine and that seems to me a
good example of both teamwork and a very
expeditious work by the manufacturers
another example of this teamwork and to
illustrate that this isn't a one-man
show is a
we have with us this evening I'd like to
present to you Dr James a Crabtree who's
associate dean of the University of
Pittsburgh Graduate School of Public
Health who will discuss how Asian
influenza has spread throughout the
world
well thank you very much Dr Bernie and
I'm also glad that Dr Crabtree is here
with us tonight too how do you do Dr
Crabtree we've been discussing the fact
that this Asian flu has covered a lot of
territory in a short time but I would
like to know how did it all get started
well the exact point of origin of the
influenza virus
is of course not known
the current epidemic
had its beginning as Dr Bernie indicated
in Hong Kong and Singapore
this was in early April
by mid-april the disease had become
indeed epidemic in both of these cities
and remain so
throughout the rest of the month
from Hong Kong and Singapore the disease
rapidly in early May
move to the island of Formosa
and here it's estimated that as many as
half million people were attacked within
a relatively short time
from Formosa also during the month of
May
the disease next made its appearance in
Borneo
and Japan
and from the major shipping centers from
these several areas
the disease very rapidly
scattered into widely such widely
separated places as Malaya
uh into China Indonesia India
Guam
in the Philippines
the first cases also in late May the
disease was reported as far away as
Australia and on board several ships on
route from Australia to San Francisco
the first appearance of the disease in
the United States was on June 2nd
this date is important
because it means only a short six weeks
from the time the first cases were
reported in China
occurred in the United States this
indicates the great rapidity with which
influenza and influenza-like diseases
can spread over over the world
by mid-june
this disease had practically circled the
globe including South East Asia
Southwest Asia and the Middle East
Europe
Australia and North America
late in June the disease made its
appearance in North Africa introduced
probably by the Muslims returning from
their pilgrimage pilgrimages to Mecca
so that finally in Late July in early
July
the disease made its appearance in Chile
in South America
so that in three short months
uh every continent on the globe had been
involved in this great pandemic
well Dr Crabtree you mentioned that it
had been reported on ships on route to
San Francisco and that several cases
were definitely diagnosed among our
Fleet at Newport Rhode Island
now wouldn't it have been comparatively
simple to have isolated these known
cases and prevented the spreading of
them and kept them from coming in at all
unfortunately not so simple for the
reason that
quarantine against
influenza is not effective had it been
possible for all of the cases on board
these ships to have been isolated
it would have had little effect
on the actual spread of the disease
because undoubtedly there were many more
people on board these same ships who by
reason of a more recently acquired
infection would have shown no symptoms
whatever of the disease and therefore
they could not have been readily
identified if they were passing through
a quarantine station I see well Dr
Bernie mentioned that we had
approximately 25
000 known cases in this nation
oh are they all bunched in one area of
the United States or has the virus
spread all over
the virus has spread all over we have
some maps here in the studio that the
television audience can see which
graphically shows how disease has spread
in the United States uh starting from
Newport Rhode Island and the West Coast
during the month of June the disease had
spread into Salt Lake City Utah
to Grinnell Iowa
Cleveland Ohio
and uh
a few cases along the east coast
if we could have the map from showing
the spread in July
we see that the disease starting from
these original centers has literally
moved in practically every direction
throughout the country then the final
map
sort of speaks for itself in that it
indicates that this virus has become
very well seeded in practically every
state in the country certainly in every
major region of the country
well I think I've got a pretty good idea
of how influenza spreads Dr Crabtree but
I'm still wondering about the virus
itself of what kind of an animal is it
a car I'd like to present to you one of
our staff from the National Institutes
of Health of the Public Health Service
Dr darling Davis who is the associate
director of Our National Institute of
allergy and infectious diseases and ask
him to answer this question any other
scientific questions that you might have
had well fine thank you again Dr Bernie
Dr Davis awfully nice to have you take
your time and come see us tonight I'm
going to ask what is probably going to
seem like a silly question but I'd like
to know what is this virus like what
what is this virus well to begin with
Carl influenza is a specific disease
caused by a specific virus
this virus was first isolated back in
1931 by Dr Schultz the Rockefeller
Institute and then subsequently in 1933
it was shown to cause human disease by
British scientists
now now we know that there are three
major classifications a virus types A B
and C
and more recently a new type of fourth
type D has been uh described in in Japan
well this um a b c and d is this fourth
type the D type is that the Asian flu Oh
no you said something about it being
related to type a that's what confuses
me the a b and c you know the type A
influenza is the influenza which
commonly causes epidemics and pandemics
at intervals throughout the uh recent
years now the Asian type of virus is a
type A and it's uh causes the kind of
disease which we have uh had in recent
years so now the uh however the
antigenic composition
of this Asian type is different from
that which we have uh
described in the more recent strains so
that a person who is immune to the older
strains is uh probably not immune to
this new strain and thus the vaccines
which have been developed in the recent
years by Dr Francis sock and others have
no probably no effect on this Invader
from Asia
I guess this is one of the reasons I
never get into medical school so a new
vaccine has to be made each time a new
strain comes along that is correct is it
yes I mean that explains why we don't
have this vaccine in stock the live
vaccine in stock yes
that is right well I think everybody's
been hearing a good deal about the Asian
flu story but uh will a person know if
he has Asian flu if so how
well I think he will know sometimes his
position finds it a little difficult to
diagnose it because the symptoms uh
maybe are similar to those caused by
other respiratory buyers are actually
respiratory bacteria
so that to be absolutely certain
we must use laboratory methods to make a
specific diagnosis
now these are generally of two kinds one
is the actual isolation of the virus or
the second is the demonstration of
antibodies which appear in the blood of
the person who while he has a disease
now this often takes a little time and
it really doesn't help the patient's
position very much
but it is important for us to know what
kind of disease is prevalent in
community and to uh this
discover what kind of what the type is
and follow its course I see well
naturally the thing most people are
concerned about is the the vaccine first
of all and particularly how it works in
the system now it seems to me that uh
being made from real Asian influenza
virus
wouldn't it be some danger in being
vaccinated no there's no danger at all a
vaccine is completely killed during the
process of being prepared
the vaccine is made by injecting this
virus into fertile chicken eggs
where the virus grows and then by
processing the fluids in the vaccine is
made by the manufacturers
it requires about 40 days to manufacture
and to test this vaccine I see well Dr
Bernie uh I can breathe a lot easier
knowing a little about how this vaccine
is made and that there isn't any live
virus in it and I'm certainly impressed
with the way your public health Team
operates I mentioned it before I want to
impress that on you for our viewers as
well as myself up to now I think that
you've given me and the rest of the
audience a complete picture of the Asian
flu
well I rather dark doubt Carl that we've
given you a complete picture because
we've left out one of the most important
groups of our total team in meeting the
challenge of this new Asian influenza
and that is the American Medical
Association which represents the
Physicians throughout our entire country
we have worked with them from the
beginning of this and have had complete
support and understanding from that
group and I would like to
present to you here now the Secretary
General Manager of the American Medical
Association Dr George Lowe thank you
again doctor Dr Lowe Mr Ryan pleasure to
have you coming here tonight too I
believe your home Port would be Chicago
that's right well Dr Lowe can you
explain a little further about this
possible flu epidemic well in planning
for a possible flu epidemic the medical
profession has three responsibilities
uh
keeping the doctors informed on the
progress of the disease
spearheading the mobilization of all
medical personnel who will be concerned
with the caring for the sake and
informing the public on what to do once
the virus is struck
the doctors are being informed
about Asian influenza through our weekly
journal and through many scientific
periodicals published by the various
States and County Medical societies
they're being encouraged to cooperate
with the Public Health Service
in detecting the presence of the virus
and its spread from Community to
community
they're being provided with late reports
on the technical aspects of the disease
and with instructions regarding the
administration of the vaccine
the American Medical Association has
asked every local medical society who
organize a committee
of those who would be involved in an
epidemic so that an agreement can be
reached in advance on such matters as
vaccine priority the handling of
transients hospital admission procedures
and so forth
and if an epidemic does strike the
medical profession will use every means
of communication possible in pamphlets
newspapers radio and television to tell
the general public what to do
it is important we feel that families
know the symptoms of the disease and the
basic points to follow in home care of
the flu victim uh what are the symptoms
Dr Lowe well at the Asian influence is
characterized by a rapid onset high
fever often as high as 104 degrees
headache sore throat aching muscles and
extreme weakness
the recognition of symptoms of course is
important early in an epidemic once the
Asian flu takes hold in the community
why you'll know what it is without
checking the symptoms well when you do
get Asian flu doctor how do you care for
it at home
well ideally your doctor should be
called and his instructions followed
however in an epidemic situation you may
not be able to give your case his
complete attention in that event these
are things to remember
first
keep away from others second go to bed
third drink a lot of fluids water and
fruit juices and fourth uh if your
doctor recommends it take a fever
reducing agent
and fifth call your doctor if any
unusual symptoms develop
what do you mean by unusual symptoms
well primarily those that would indicate
the onset of some lung involvement a
heavy cough rapid breathing bonus of the
lips I see well thank you very much Dr
law and I'm going to ask Dr Bernie if he
would summarize our discussion
this fall and winter we may see serious
outbreaks of influenza in the United
States as a consequence of the epidemics
which began last April in the Far East
unlike similar instances in the past
however
we believe that the size and severity of
the epidemics can in this be minimized
in this country
thus it is the opinion of experts that
there is no need for hysteria or panic
the influenza is concerned in the first
place we are prepared for The Invasion
and in the second place we now have the
means through a new vaccine to help
prevent this influenza perhaps the story
of infection by influenza virus can best
be summarized in this manner
there is a pandemic of worldwide
epidemic of Asian influenza which has
attacked most of the nations of the
world
laboratory tests have shown that it
definitely has reached the United States
attacking both military and civilian
personnel
the virus causing this influenza has
been isolated and recognized as a member
of The Familiar type of a virus
an effective and safe vaccine has been
developed as a preventive and currently
is in production by six pharmaceutical
houses in this country
at the present time Asian influenza can
best be classified as a mild virus
disease
which attacks many people but has a very
low death rate
experts say that it is probable that an
epidemic will occur in this nation
sometime between late fall and early
winter
for the first time in history
a nation our own United States is in the
fortunate position of being ahead of an
impending epidemic and thus has had the
time to organize for an all-out
offensive against Asian influenza
there is always the possibility of an
increase in variance of the infection as
the epidemic increases
however the new vaccine has been proven
effective in control studies conducted
by the military
and should be an excellent weapon to
combat the disease if the epidemic
progresses
when the vaccine is made available for
public use
the Public Health Service and the
American Medical Association hope that
the nation as a whole will participate
in a voluntary program of vaccination
against the prevalence of this influenza
rest assured that there is no need for
alarm Panic or hysteria
if there is a change in the situation
you will be informed immediately through
the public education channels of your
American Medical Association United
States Public Health Service and state
and territorial Health officers
this program by the way which is a
result of the combined efforts of
organized medicine
Private Industry and education is an
excellent example of the type of public
information and education we are setting
up
in closing I would like to urge you to
make use of the new vaccine when it
becomes available
knowing meanwhile that you will
cooperate with the medical profession
and the public health authorities if it
becomes necessary to set up priorities
for those groups responsible for public
welfare and safety and who must continue
their important Services if others of us
are temporarily incapacitated by Asian
influenza
well Dr Bernie I'm sure I speak for all
who have been with us during this
program when I say how much we
appreciate all of you gentlemen taking
your valuable time to come here so that
we might be better informed on Asian flu
and what is being done about it
participants on tonight's show have been
Dr LeRoy e Bernie Surgeon General of the
United States Public Health Service
Dr James a Crabtree associate dean of
the University of Pittsburgh Graduate
School of Public Health
Dr Dolan J Davis associate director in
charge of research of the National
Institute of allergy and infectious
diseases United States Public Health
Services
Dr George F Lowell secretary and general
manager of the American Medical
Association
Asylum Invader was written by Tom
Coleman
produced by Roger wolf
directed by Jack Simon
script research by Rosemarie scottiello
and Kay McDonough
Asylum Invader has been brought to you
as a public service by the Westinghouse
Broadcasting Company in cooperation with
the American Medical Association
the Public Health Service of the U.S
department of health education and
Welfare
and the University of Pittsburgh Health
Center